Der fund ist echt ziemlich mysteriös eine antike totenstadt nicht nur eine goldmaske sondern auch tausende
Statuen und 40 stein särge hat ein forschungsteam jetzt in ägypten unterirdisch entdeckt eine antike totenstadt
also die wohl unfassbar wichtige einblicke in das leben der alten ägypter offenbar wird alles zu den geheimnisvollen kunden jetzt endlich zum science fiction
herzlich willkommen
Ja wir haben ja schon öfter darüber berichtet ergibt er hat schon jetzt wirklich unfassbar
kulturstätten zu bieten die pyramiden von gizeh die pharaonen stadt das grab von
Tutanchamun und so weiter und so fort und es kommen immer mehr dazu
Jetzt wurde eine weitere sensationelle entdeckung aus der hochkultur des landes veröffentlicht
2500 jahre alt ist sowohl die riesige totenstadt die jetzt im ägyptischen mini entdeckt wurde die
Ausgrabungen wurden schon im vergangenen jahr in der historischen stätte thuner algarve
gestartet zitat das ist erst der anfang einer neuen entdeckung und ich glaube wir brauchen mindestens fünf jahre um die arbeit an der
nekropole zu beenden sagt der ägyptische minister kaletta lena
Lee ja das
forschungsteam verspricht sich durch diese funde neue einblicke in das leben der alten ägypter zu bekommt denn neben dieser entdeckung die wohl aus der
26 dynastie der alten ägypter stammt seien noch weitere funde zu erwarten nach
Ihrem glauben lebten die verstorbenen nach ihrem tod
im jenseits weiter und diese metropolen also diese
toten städte sind wirklich besonders mysteriös denn solche ägyptischen friedhöfe sind nicht nur einfache
grabanlagen sondern kultstätten toten städte die grad bauten waren als eine art ewiger
aufenthaltsort gedacht glücklicherweise sind tatsächlich viele solcher gräber der gehobenen
gesellschaftsschichten erhalten geblieben beispielsweise beamten oder
königsgräber ein sehr großes gräberfeld das sogenannte theben west liegt gegenüber von nutzer
das verantwortliche ministerium in ägypten hat bereits in den letzten monaten einige spannende
Entdeckung verkündet aber die jetzt veröffentlichten aus grabungsergebnisse vom mini sind wirklich ja der hammer darunter sind beispielsweise
Mehrere grabkammern von priestern die dem gott tot also
Tht geschrieben zugehörig waren das ist der gott des mondes der schrift und des lernens
Charakteristisch ist sein vogelkopf in einem der gräber wurde die mumie. Des hohepriesters
Hsa gefunden seine überreste sind verziert mit bronze zudem wurden zahlreiche
keramikfiguren entdeckt 1000 davon etwa sind gut erhalten
Wenn man das so verfolgt dann ist in ägypten noch eine menge zu entdecken und durch moderne technologien kommen wir immer mehr
Geheimnissen auf die spur letztlich habe ich ja hier erst über die
verborgene kammer in der cheops-pyramide berichtet schirms pyramiden sie war mit hilfe von millionen entdeckt worden und ein
Weiteres spannendes ausgaben projekt läuft gerade in der grabkammer des pharaos tutanchamun, im tal der könige
1922 wurde diese grabkammer entdeckt und jetzt sollen
radarmessung feststellen ob sich dort ein bislang
unentdeckter raum befindet denn genau diese vermutung haben die forschungsteams es könnte vielleicht das grab von nofretete sein
und das wäre dann wahrscheinlich eine der
Spektakulärsten funde überhaupt ja wenn er als erstes neues dazu und zu allen anderen themen erfahren wollt dann
meldet euch hierbei whatsapp an dann erfahrt ihr von mir vor allen anderen vom neuesten video vorab eben
garantiert ihr könnt dort direkt in der redaktion von kriegs- und mitmachen und mit themen vorschlagen oder
mit abstimmungen bei abstimmungen mit bestimmen die whatsapp haben zb entschieden dass ich mir meine haare demnächst
violett färben muss zur feier der 200 millionen dosen oder der direkte draht zu mir ist das also einfach draufklicken
Und natürlich nicht das abo mit der genau der glocke vergessen hier geht es weiter mit dafür auch drauf klicken
Ja da geht es um die geheimnisvolle
Neu entdeckte kammer in der shops pyramide ansonsten bis dann
bleibt dann